PROFESSOR: --called
case studies.
That is, we really look
at how some of the tools
that we have learned
during this class--
some of the energy tools, like
density functional theory,
some of the statistical
tools, like thermodynamic
integration-- come
together and are actually
used to predict the properties
of materials and structures
of real interest.
This is-- I called
it lecture 20,
but I think I have been slightly
inconsistent with the numbering
of my lectures.
We count also the labs.
Anyhow, everything
is on the web.
So what will you learn
today is actually
how to become an expert
in two of these jobs
for the 21st century.
One is the virtual alchemist,
and the one that is fancier,
I think, is the
nanotechnologist.
There was probably an
ad for GE a few months
ago on TV in which there was
a nanotechnologist marrying
a supermodel.
It was sort of fairly
intriguing for all of us
doing the initial calculations.
But more seriously, what we
are really going to focus on
is how can we break the n-cube
barrier of electronic structure
calculation.
You have learned that, say,
when we study a system using
density functional theory,
the computational cost scales
as the cube of the
number of atoms.
And that basically
scales very rapidly
the size of the system
that you can do.
I mean, even on a
supercomputer nowadays,
we can't really do more
than 500 atoms, say.
And on a regular cluster, we are
more likely close to 100 atoms.
And the reason of the
cubic scaling in DFT
is ultimately due to the
orthonormality constraints.
Every single particle
orbital needs
to be orthogonal to every
other single particle orbital.
So if you double the
size of your system,
you double the
number of electrons.
That is, you have
twice as many orbitals
that need to be orthogonal with
twice as many other orbitals.
So you have four times
more matrix elements
that you need to calculate.
But also, those
matrix elements are
calculated in a unit cell
that is twice as large.
So there is another
factor of two,
and that gives us
a factor of eight.
And of course, there is a lot
of effort in the community
nowadays to go towards linear
scaling algorithm, algorithm
that just double in
computational cost
when you double the
size of your unit cell.
And they are all based on the
sort of physical principle
that, in many ways,
nature is local.
So your electron needs only to
know what's happening nearby
and doesn't need to be really
orthogonal to electrons
that are very, very far away.
And you see an example of sort
of where this linear scaling
direction are heading.
Other methods scale
even worse than cubic.
We have sort of discussed that
sort of standard Hartree-Fock
scales as the full power,
and highly correlated
quantum chemistry methods scale
as the fifth, sixth, seventh
power.
An interesting
exception, I think,
among the methods that try
to go beyond DFT in accuracy
is what people call quantum
Monte Carlo approaches.
They tend to be approaches that
are very accurate but based
on a stochastic sampling
of the wave function,
so really, a stochastic
solution for the wave
function in the
Schrodinger equation.
And those in principle
scale as the cube.
And there have been
sort of recent progress
in making them truly
linear scaling.
So I think they are a
very promising avenue
for the future.
But in this class, we'll sort
of confine ourselves to DFT.
And in particular, we'll look
at two examples in which we
use electronic structure DFT
calculation to actually obtain
the relevant parameters
for a Hamiltonian
that basically models the
important degrees of freedom
for our system.
So we'll actually look at
semiconductor alloys, where
you'll see, very
naturally, one can sort of
solve the problem of
substitutional disorder
on that alloy using an
Ising-like Hamiltonian, so
something that you have seen
in the previous classes.
And then we'll look
at another example
to functionalize
nanotubes, that is
carbon nanotubes, to
which organic ligands have
been covalently attached.
And you'll see how we sort
of develop a linear scaling
tight binding-like procedure.
We'll explain this.
That allows us
actually to study,
with full DFT precision, systems
that have tens of thousands
of atoms in the units cell.
So let's start with
the first example, that
of semiconductor alloys.
Semiconductor alloys have
been of central interest
since, I would say,
the late 80s, when
people started to realize that
there wasn't only silicon.
And in particular, it was
very important to tune
out the physical properties
of your semiconductor,
and alloying is a very
simple way of doing that.
If you, say, mix together
something like gallium arsenide
and aluminum arsenide,
depending on the concentration,
you have a substitutional
alloy with a bandgap
that is variable.
So it can be used
very efficiently, say,
to tune the emission
frequency of your laser light,
if this semiconductor
is your active layer.
And this is something
which, in our department,
in the material
science course, there
is a lot of ongoing effort.
In particular,
Professor Fitzgerald
works a lot on some
of these alloys
to actually improve
mobility of the carriers.
And I had here some kind
of beautiful picture
of actually an array
of vertical KVT lasers
in which sort of a number
of vertical pillars
were grown on a surface
with a composition
gradient for that active layer.
So what you achieve
on a single breadboard
is a very high density
of emitting lasers.
And each one emits at a
slightly different wavelength,
because the bandgap is tuned
by the compositional gradient
in that array.
And another set of reasons that
sort of intrigued and prompted
the study of the
semiconductor alloys
was actually what is
called the ordering,
multilayer ordering,
superlattice
ordering in those alloys.
That is, when doing
X-ray diffraction
of a standard semiconductor, you
would get a set of broad pixel.
And what people note is
that under certain growth
circumstances, they would find
naturally in the diffraction
figures some intermediate peaks.
So in this case, some peaks
are closer to the origin,
or in this case, sort
of the green dots.
So yeah, midway between
the two red dots.
What it means is that
there is actually
some kind of ordering
that has periodicity that
is in that particular
crystallography direction,
has a wavelength that
is twice as large
or a wave vector
that is one half.
And so it sort of hints
at some kind of ordering.
So there were a
number of reasons
why these were interesting.
And I'll show you sort of one
of the ways one could actually
tackle the problem of
studying these systems.
I had another figure here.
They just didn't come--
they didn't come out--
in which, again, I was
sort of showing you
basically the whole
set of semiconductors
and plotting that as a
function of lattice parameter
and bandgap.
And basically showing that,
if you look at all, say,
the III-V semiconductor,
they sit in a certain region
of this diagram.
But in reality,
there isn't anything
that is really useful that--
say, as the bandgap of silicon.
But it meets at the wavelength
for which conventional fiber
optics cables are transparent.
And so a lot of effort in
trying to engineer alloys
or new materials that go towards
that soft spot in which you
can grow things that seem
more thick on silicon.
So you can use all your
silicon technology,
but they have the
right direct bandgap
that is appropriate to
optical fibers, 1.5 microns.
OK, so from the conceptual or
computational point of view,
our problem is really
trying to figure out
a way to calculate efficiently
the energetics and the phase
ability of a
semiconductor alloy.
And I sort of shown
you here an example.
Remember, semiconductors have
the diamond or the zinc blende
structure.
So they are made by two, say,
interpenetrating lattices.
And what I'm showing
here is just one
of the two FCC sub-lattices of
a typical zinc blende structure.
Say, suppose that you are
studying gallium aluminum
arsenide.
Arsenic is the group
V semiconductor.
Gallium and aluminum
are group III.
So you would have
a sub-lattice where
gallium and aluminum
sit, and this
is what you are looking at.
It's an FCC sub-lattice--
and where there
can be substitutional disorder.
On each side, there is
a certain probability
of finding either a
gallium or an aluminum that
is basically proportional
to the concentration.
So if you have a
50/50 alloy, you
will have 50% probability
of finding gallium
in a certain side.
And then there is a
second sub-lattice
that is almost
invisible that would
be given by the anion
or the arsenic side.
Of course, one could
sort of study this system
with a sort of brute
force approach.
We could really look
at large supercell,
and perform many
calculations, and find out
which arrangement of atoms give
us lower energy configuration,
figure out what, say,
would be the bandgap
or what would be the
lattice parameter
of certain
configuration, and try
to figure out what are the
macroscopic properties.
But statistics at this stage
will always be limited.
If you want to study a
supercell that is large enough,
you probably need,
again, a cell in which
the correlation between
faraway atoms is lost,
and you might easily need
something like 100 atoms.
But then in particular,
you need a lot
of statistics that are true to
the 100 ways of arranging atoms
on that lattice.
And you can only
calculate a few of these.
And so you become very limited
in analyzing the thermodynamics
of your problem.
At the end, what you
really care about
is understanding what is the
energy of a configuration.
That is, what is the energy as
a function of-- you have seen
this before--
configuration of variable sigma.
We use the nomenclature in
which sigma is equal to 1,
if, say, we have a
gallium atom here.
This example
specifically is actually
for gallium indium
phosphide, so we'll have,
again, group III indium.
And sigma equal to minus 1.
That means that there
is indium on one side.
This will make actually the
connection with the Ising model
very, very apparent.
And so what you want to do
is calculate the energetics
of a lot of configuration
and then extract
the thermodynamic properties.
And you have seen
already in Professor
[? Seder's ?]
lectures, and you'll
see again partially in this
lecture and the next lecture
how you can use actually
Monte Carlo approaches
to extract basically what
are the average ensemble
properties.
But our first goal
for us is actually
finding out an inexpensive
way to calculate
the energy of an arbitrary
configuration of atoms,
without having to do the
explicit first principle
calculation.
And this is where the
fundamental concept
that you'll see in this
lecture comes about.
That is, how we actually devise
from the initial calculation,
how we extract from the initial
calculation, the parameters
for the model Hamiltonian
that describes
the energetic of my system for
any arbitrary configuration.
And as usual, you
need to put ingenuity
in solving a difficult problem.
And this is one of
the possible solution.
You'll actually see some
of different alternative
approaches in one
of the next lecture.
But what we are doing
here is, we are actually
sort of exploiting the fact
that, say, if you are looking
at a substitutional alloy,
you have substitutions
on a sub-lattice between atoms
that are really chemically very
similar.
If you are studying, say,
gallium indium phosphide,
gallium and indium are going
to be chemically very similar.
They are both group III.
They are just sort of in a
slightly different in shape.
And of course, their orbitals
will be sort of slightly
different, and they
will correspond
to a different period
in the periodic table.
But their chemical properties
are still fairly similar.
And so for a moment, we
could actually think--
and I'll show you how it
works mathematically--
that a real configuration
of a crystal--
and remember, from the point
of view of density function
theory, having a
certain arrangement
of red and blue atoms
means that there
are very specific
pseudo potentials
sitting on each
one of the sides.
But one of these
arrangements could actually
be sort of considered as
a perturbation on what we
call a virtual crystal,
a crystal that has
full translational symmetry.
So the sort of idea that
I'm trying to give you--
and we'll see it
mathematically in a way--
is that we could think at the
real configuration of a system
as a perturbation in which
we take a pseudo atom that
doesn't exist but
is somehow very
similar to both
gallium and indium.
And then we turn that
with a small change
in the pseudo potential in
either gallium or indium.
And if we can do
that, well, then we
can study this problem with
density functional theory,
because this is
actually a system that
has two atoms per unit cell.
And then we can try and
use perturbation theory
to figure out what would be
the energy of our configuration
over there.
And this is actually
fairly trivial
to sort of see it in
mathematical form,
when you actually
think again at the fact
that in density
functional theory,
the potential acting
on the electron
is really given by this
array of pseudo potential
sitting on lattice sides.
And so if we have a real
configuration-- remember,
the red and blue
crystal on the left--
well, to that, it
will correspond
an external potential that is
an array of red and blue pseudo
potential, that can
actually be rewritten
in terms of the semi-sum and
the semi-difference of pseudo
potential.
So this would be the
exact expression.
We have the true
pseudo potential
on each sort of FCC
sub-lattice site.
But we write, say,
gallium pseudo potential
as being given by the sum of
the average between the gallium
and the indium pseudo
potential, say, plus one
half the semi-difference.
You see, if I'm
sitting on a site,
and I'm telling you that
the pseudo potential acting
on that side is going to be
the sum between the average
between gallium and indium plus
one half the semi-difference,
you see that the indium cancels
out, and the gallium sums up.
And what you have is the
gallium pseudo potential there.
And so a sigma variable
equal to plus 1 at the site R
really gives you a gallium
pseudo potential in that site.
And a sigma variable
equal to minus 1
gives you an indium pseudo
potential in that site.
But in this form, and in the
limit in which the two pseudo
potential are
fairly similar, you
can see that this term
is actually small.
The more similar
gallium and indium
are, the smaller this system is.
But this term here
overall is the only one
where the configurational
variables are present.
There are no configurational
variable here.
And so this represents, really,
the green average virtual
crystal to which
at every site, we
add or subtract depending
on the sign of sigma
R, the semi-difference of
the two pseudo potential.
And this term really
turns a green atom
in a red or blue atom.
And for the specific case
of semiconductor alloys,
this term is smaller,
because disorder
takes place between atoms
that are very small.
And so what we are going to do
is use density function theory
to study this crystal then
use perturbation theory
to understand what is going on
when we do this perturbation.
And so this is also
sort of a chance
for me to at least
hint at how we actually
perform perturbation theory
in density functional theory
itself.
And that's a very useful tool.
Say, it's used,
and you'll see it,
and you have seen it
before, to calculate things
like phonon dispersions.
That is, what is
the force or what
is the frequency of perturbation
in the atomic position
with a certain
wavelength that is really
the normal mode of the crystal.
Or it can be used in
a variety of problems,
say, to study what is
the response of a system
to an electric field
and then calculate
Raman or infrared spectra.
It can be used to calculate
the response of a system
to a magnetic field and then
calculate the NMR spectra,
or it can even be used
to calculate higher order
important physical quantities.
If we go to sort of
higher order response,
we can start to calculate
what is the third order
Hamiltonian in the
phonons, so what are the--
in the phonons, what are
the lifetime of phonons.
Or we can calculate how an
electronic state couples
with a phonon state.
And so we can actually
get out the parameters,
say, for superconductivity.
That is, when electrons travel
through a crystal paired
because of the interaction with
the phonon degrees of freedom.
Or we could calculate, say,
resonant Raman scattering
that, again, is sort of a strong
electron-phonon component.
But in general, the
problem is just this.
Perturbation theory
looks at what
happens to a certain system that
has an external potential v0
when you add a perturbation.
And the perturbation is
sort of parameterized
by a certain strength lambda.
So for small lambda, the
perturbation is weak.
So we are sort of thinking
at the limit of what happens
when the perturbation is weak.
So you add a lambda delta v
term to your external potential.
And in this specific
case, that delta v term
is going to be that
semi-difference
between the pseudo potential.
So it's the term that really
transform a virtual atom
in a real gallium
and in a real indium.
What happens when you apply
this small perturbation is that,
of course, your new
self-consistent charge density
will change.
So if, for a given
external potential v0,
you add a ground state charge
density n0 for a perturbation
in which you add the
term lambda delta v,
your new ground
state charge density
is going to be a certain
charge density that
will define us n lambda.
But we can think
of this n lambda
as being sort of expanded in a
power series of power lambdas.
So the new n lambda is going to
be given by the original ground
state charge density
plus a term that we
call the linear response that
is a first order in lambda,
plus a term that is a
second-order response,
plus a term that is third
order and fourth order
and so on and so forth.
And the smaller the lambda
is, the less relevant
will be the higher order terms.
And what is really important is
just this first order response
in the charge density.
And this actually sort of
gives us a lot of power.
That is, just knowing the first
order response in the charge
density allows us to calculate
the energy of a system
in the presence of
this perturbation
up to the second order.
And this basically
can be seen by using
Hellmann-Feynman theorem here.
This is-- you have seen it sort
of when we discussed forces,
and it's really a sort of direct
consequence of the ground state
properties of the orbitals
in the Schrodinger equation.
But basically, what does
Hellmann-Feynman theorem
tells us?
Well, it tells us
that if we need
to look at the change
in energy with respect
to a certain perturbation,
the only thing
that we need to
calculate is actually
the expectation value of
the orbitals with respect
to the perturbation.
So this is really
Hellmann-Feynman theorem.
You might remember this.
We have discussed it.
We don't need to take into
account the derivative
of, say, lambda--
sorry, I'm using too
many lambdas here.
But let's call it
lambda again here.
We don't need to take into
account the changes in the wave
functions themselves.
We just calculate the
expectation value.
So for any given
arbitrary lambda,
the derivative of the
energy, the change
in the energy with
respect to lambda,
is just given by
this simple integral.
And so you see that if we
then say that we actually
expand the energy up to the
first-order term, what we have
is that the energy is
equal to e0 plus lambda d
e over d lambda.
And then there would be a
one half lambda square term.
But then in itself,
we can expand--
it's a little bit
father, so I'm sort
of skipping some of the
passages-- we can expand this n
lambda in powers of lambda.
And so what you see is
that up to the second order
in lambda, the
only terms that are
relevant in the expansion
of your energy--
and this is what is important--
are, for the first order
term, just the integral
of the perturbation with respect
to the ground state's charge
density, and for the
second-order term,
the integral of the perturbation
with the first order
change in the charge density.
So perturbation
induces a change.
And if we are able to calculate
the linear response to that,
this n1, we actually
get correction
to the energy up to
the second-order term.
And so there is a whole branch
of density functional theory
that's called density functional
perturbation theory that
really deals on how to calculate
this linear order perturbation.
And I really won't
go into the detail.
The sort of other
difficulty with respect
to a standard set of quantum
mechanical perturbation theory
is that in density
functional theory,
the Hamiltonian is in
itself self-consistent.
And so you have an added
layer of complexity,
because it depends from
the charge density itself.
And so when you have
got a perturbation
in your external
potential, the perturbation
in your Kohn-Sham potential
contains also term
in the Hartree and in the
exchange correlation term.
So we won't really go
into these details,
but there is, again, an
iterative self-consistent
procedure to obtain the
self-consistent linear order
response to an
external perturbation.
And all of this is actually
implemented in the PWSCF code.
So some of you might
at certain point
need to use that, again,
to calculate quantities
like the phonon dispersions.
And there are actually
examples in the distribution
that tell you how to do that.
And so if we go back to our
original problem, all of this
was actually to
convince you that if we
are able to calculate
this linear response,
the first order change in
the charge density induced
by a certain
perturbation, we actually
have the energy of a system
up to the second order
in the perturbation, where
the first order term, again,
is just given by the integral
of the ground state charge
density in the perturbation.
And the second
order term is given
by the integral of
the linear response
times the perturbation.
But you see, what is
now the fundamental step
is that these
quantities don't depend
on the configurational
variables.
These are quantities that
are calculated on the ground
state-- that is,
the green crystal--
something that doesn't
depend on configuration.
So this can be calculated
once and for all just
on the system that contains
two atoms per unit cell.
And once you have
calculated this,
this will give you the
energy up to the second order
in the configurational
variables.
So doing this calculation
will take some time,
but it's really on a
two-atom unit cell.
But once you have
this, what you have
is really a analytical
and extremely inexpensive
expression to calculate the
energy up to the second order.
So as long as your
disorder is weak,
you will get a very good
approximation of the energy
just by doing this set of
sums that a computer will
take probably a nanosecond
or something like this.
And again, this really
looks like an Ising model
Hamiltonian.
If you remember what you
had in the Ising model--
is that you had a sort of
coupling between nearby spins
that was parameterized by a
certain exchange parameter
here.
The only difference
is that, being these
are semiconductor
alloys, interactions
tend to be long range.
And so it's not only atoms or
sigma variables sitting nearby
that sort of interact, but
the interaction sort of
goes on farther and farther.
And so it's a sort of long
range Ising Hamiltonian.
But once you have this, you
can do all the thermodynamics
that you want to your problem
and very inexpensively.
I'll sort of go very
quickly through this.
But again, what we have seen
up to now is really this sort
of fundamental concept that
the electronic structure
calculation or our energy
calculation allows us
to extract parameters--
in this case,
the J interaction constants--
that gives us the
energy of our system.
And as usual, when
you really need
to find out what are the
parameters to extract,
you need to think at what
are your relevant degrees
of freedom.
So you need to think at the
physics of your problem.
And if you have a
semiconductor alloy,
the first degree of freedom
that comes to mind correctly
is the configurational
degree of freedom.
That is, we can have on a
certain site one atom, gallium,
or another atom, indium.
But actually, it's not the
only degrees of freedom that is
relevant, because depending on
which atom you put on a certain
side, what you have is that,
depending on also what is
the surrounding environment-- if
it's a gallium between gallium
atoms or if it's a gallium
between indium atoms--
that atom will see
a broken symmetry.
And so it will want to
relax from the ideal sort
of periodic Bravais
lattice position
and will likely
like to move around,
either to make space
for larger atoms that
are nearby or sort of to make
space for itself if there
are smaller atoms.
And so this is sort of where
intuition becomes important.
And so you need to decide
what are the important degrees
of freedom.
And in this case,
what we are saying
is that there are not only
configurational variables that
are important
degrees of freedom,
but there are also displacements
of the atoms in response
to a certain configuration
away from equilibrium.
And so once you have
identified that there
is this second set of
degrees of freedom,
well, what you are really
saying is that we really
need to consider, in the
expansion of the energy
over all my degrees
of freedom, not
only the configurational
variables but also
the displacement
of an atom, say,
from its equilibrium position.
And so we need to
expand their energy up
to the second order, not only
in configuration but also
in displacements.
And because we are expanding
up to the second order
in configuration and
in displacements,
there is going to be
also a mixed term that
is half configuration
and half displacement.
If you want this
term, think of F
as being the second derivative
of the energy with respect
to u and with respect
towards sigma.
So this term here
is telling us what
is the force that is
induced on the atom R
when, on the side R prime,
there is a certain atom given
by the configurational
variable sigma.
So we really need to expand
in all our degrees of freedom.
But then we can
do something more.
And we can even sort of apply
an equilibrium condition.
Because at the end, what we
want to do for the system is not
really the dynamics, but
what we really want to do
is the thermodynamics of the
different configurations.
So what we are
saying is that, well,
suppose that we have chosen a
certain configuration of atoms.
Now, what we really need
to take into account
is not only how the
energy changes but also
how the atom moves around to
accommodate the configuration
as best as possible.
But that really means that
the atoms will move in order
to minimize the
energy, or if you want,
in order to have really zero
force at a certain point.
If you start from
the periodic lattice
and you sort of decide a certain
configuration, on those sites,
there will be forces.
Atoms move a little bit
away from that site,
so that their force is 0.
So what we have is here the
sort of physical embodiment
of the degrees of freedom.
The energy is expanded
up to the second order.
But then we also apply
an equilibrium condition.
That is, the force on the ions
for a given configuration sigma
must be 0.
So the derivative, the
first order derivative
of the energy with displacement,
that is the force, must be 0.
And if you apply that at this
and you work the algebra,
you really obtain,
for a given set
of configurational variable,
what are the displacements away
from equilibrium
that are induced
by this configurational
variable.
And of course, they are mediated
by this response function
of our system, the
force on an atom induced
by our configurational
variable, and really,
the second-order
derivative, the stiffness
of our potential energy
surface with respect
to atomic displacements.
And so we use this
equilibrium condition.
That is, for a
given configuration,
the displacement
are really given.
And we take it, and we
stick it back inside.
So we substitute, for the green
u of R, this expression here.
Those are all sort of
tensorial quantities
which I sort of
removed the sums.
But so we are back to our
spin Ising Hamiltonian
in which the only
thing that is relevant
is the configurational
variables,
because at the end, that's the
only thing that can happen.
We can have a certain
atom in a certain place,
but we take into account the
fact that the ions sort of
go back, move to equilibrium.
And we take that into
account by a renormalization
of the interaction
constant j by, if you want,
the displacement term or what
we would call the elastic terms.
OK, so we have all the tools to
calculate this regional j, this
that would be nothing else
than the dynamical force
constant matrix
that you diagonalize
in your final calculation
or this mixed term that
in the literature are
called Kanzaki forces.
We do this on the
virtual crystal.
And then we really have
our spin Hamiltonian,
including the energetics
effects of atomic displacements.
And so we have really the
Hamiltonian of our system,
and we can start doing
the thermodynamics of it,
with a small caveat that
what we have done up to now
is really this step.
We have been able
to calculate, if you
want, the energy of a
certain configuration,
starting from a virtual crystal.
But we haven't really-- and this
is a subtlety that I won't go
into the detail--
we haven't really
taken into account
that our sort of end
original products
have actually different
lattice parameters.
So in itself, at
the end, if we need
to understand phased
ability, we need
to understand what
is the lower Gibbs
free energy for our
problem, that is,
if entropy drives
this configuration
to be stable, or, if you
want, if enthalpy and elastic
interaction drive
segregation in two
compounds with different
lattice parameters
to be the stable state.
And of course, the closer
the lattice parameters
are, the more irrelevant
this term is going to be
and the more relevant
term in which
the disorder atoms will be.
And temperature is always
going to favor this.
But this might
become very expensive
if the original compounds
have very different lattice
parameters, because
we really need
to stretch things
to start having
the possibility of
mixing them together.
And all sort of-- the
phase diagonal stability
of this system is really driven
by these two competing sort
of forces, the
temperature that want
to mix up things
around but chemistry
that, in order to
mix things around,
you need to have atoms that
are chemically very similar.
And you need to have
lattice parameters that
are fairly similar, so that you
don't build up a lot of strain.
And so, again, without
going into detail,
it is actually very
easy to calculate
some of those elastic terms.
And so when we do that,
what we really have is a way
to calculate how much energy it
takes to stretch things so they
have the same sort of unit
cell and then how much--
and that was the tricky part--
it cost to mix things
around, it cost
to have a certain configuration.
And the very nice
thing is that now, we
can sort of test our
perturbation theory approach
and compare it with full blown
density functional theory
calculations for
cells that are small
enough so that you can actually
do a density functional theory
calculation.
These are older results.
Now we could do
much larger cells.
But the concept stands.
We can do a full self-consistent
calculation, say,
for a super lattice of
gallium planes and indium
planes in the 111 direction.
And so we can calculate
what is the lattice
parameter of this
structure and what
is actually the sort
of Gibbs free energy
of mixing for this system.
And we can do that with a
full explicit calculation,
and we can do it with a set
of perturbation approach.
And you see, we can compare the
equilibrium lattice parameters
in both cases.
And basically, the difference--
this is atomic units.
This is PWSCF-- is
basically negligible.
And the energies
are also very good.
This sort of error that the
perturbation theory makes
is actually here, just 1
millielectron volt per atom.
And as you sort of
move around, you
see that there are lot of cases
in which the error is larger,
4 millielectron volt.
And 4 millielectron
volt is very small,
but it's still
10% of this mixing free energy.
So it's sort of
somehow relevant.
But we, I would say,
still do very well.
And calculating this
energy of mixing
is absolutely inexpensive.
It takes a nanosecond
on your computer.
You just basically sum with
the appropriate configurational
variables the term with
your interaction constants.
This requires a full
self-consistent calculation.
So with this approach, you
can calculate the energies
of millions of
structures that are
very large, while with
this, you can only
calculate tens of structures
that are reasonably small.
So it's very appropriate to
use the linear response term
to then do-- to use one of these
statistical sampling methods
that you have seen with
Professor [? Seder. ?]
And again, I won't go
into detail, because you
have seen them
partially, and you'll
see them over and over again.
But just to remind you
sort of the concepts,
if you want to
understand what is
the stability of a certain
structure, what you really
need to compare are
their Gibbs free energy.
So you want to operate into the
thermodynamic ensemble in which
you have constant pressure
and constant temperature,
because that's really
what your experiment is.
You're at a certain temperature,
and you let the system relax.
And as usual, you
can't calculate--
explicitly, there
is not a formula
that gives you free energy.
It's a logarithm of a
partitioned function.
And so there are sort
of statistical ways
by which that can be calculated.
And one of the most
powerful approaches
is that given by
thermodynamic integration.
That really is based on the fact
that while we can't calculate
free energy, we can
actually calculate
the derivative of free energy.
So the derivative of the
free energy with a certain
parameter, like the
derivative of the free energy,
the Gibbs free energy
with respect to the number
of particles, is actually going
to be given by the ensemble
average-- that's when we
use the sort of brackets,
the bracket sort of symbol--
by the ensemble average of
the derivative of the energy
with respect to the
number of particles.
So that allows us to calculate
derivatives of free energy
in the appropriate
thermodynamic ensemble.
And so what we can do
is calculate free energy
differences by integrating
the derivative of free energy
from state A and state B.
And obviously, this integral
will be done by step-wise
calculating these derivatives
at different points.
But these derivatives, that
in the case of the Gibbs
free energy with respect to the
number of particles, nothing
less than the chemical
potential as a function
of the concentration,
needs to be evaluated
for every concentration.
Say, in going from concentration
A to concentration B,
what we really
want to figure out
is what is the free energy
difference between these two
concentration.
So each of these
points in this integral
requires an entire
statistical sampling and then
an entire statistical
simulation.
And so this is what
you would actually do.
You choose a temperature,
say, 1,000 kelvin,
and you choose a pressure, say,
0 pressure or 1 atmosphere,
that for all practical
purposes is 0.
And then under these
conditions, you
have your total energy expressed
in configurational variables.
And you decide what is your
chemical potential, that is,
what is sort of the
additional cost of switching
an atom from gallium to indium.
And then you start with
your Monte Carlo sampling.
You keep switching atoms
from gallium to indium
or from indium to gallium.
Each of these switches
will have a certain energy
cost that is weighed with
the Metropolis factor.
And in this simulation,
at a given pressure
and at a given
chemical potential,
after of millions of sweeps and
millions of trials in which you
try to change a spin variable
from plus 1 or minus 1,
you do this over and over again,
and you end up with a point
there that tells you what is
the concentration of, say,
gallium 0.9 for a given
chemical potential.
And you repeat this
over and over again.
That is, you sweep all your
possible chemical potential.
And for each choice
of chemical potential,
you get a certain
average concentration.
And so you do this
over and over again.
And so you see, what
you get is a curve
that tells you what is the
concentration as a function
of the chemical potential.
And you get one of these
curves for each temperature
at which you do the simulation.
So you get concentration as a
function of chemical potential.
And if we go back for a
moment to the previous slide,
this is really the
inverse of what you need.
You need the
thermodynamic integration
to calculate the free energy
difference between two
concentration, the integral of
the average chemical potential
for a given concentration.
So the only thing
that you have to do
is, really, look at this curve,
turn it around if you want to,
so that you have x
as a function of mu.
And say, for the
1,000 kelvin case,
you'll have something like this.
So you have sort of inverted--
your simulations have given
you concentration as a function
of chemical potential.
You invert that, and
you integrate it,
and you get a free energy curve.
And you see, things
get interesting
when you start being below
a critical temperature.
So you see, we got 820 kelvin.
And you really see that the
curve is still continuous,
but it sort of starts to have
a slope in the middle that
is going towards infinity.
And if we go below, at
650 kelvin, what happens
is that we have opened
a miscibility gap.
That is, there is a region of
concentrations from 0.1 to 0.8
that never appear.
So at 650 kelvin,
this system doesn't
want to mix in the concentration
regime between 0.8 and 0.1.
And this is typical
of model alloys.
Miscibility gap has opened.
The two things don't mix.
And if you think at sort of
how your curve could look like,
we could sort of
somehow interpolate
in some arbitrary way this
curve and then invert it.
And when you
integrate the data--
it seems that the
computer has gone mad.
And let's see.
OK, we'll keep
the green forever.
It's now in the realm
of the computer.
But this is good, because
when you invert this
and you integrate,
what you see is
that for your free energy as a
function of the concentration--
is that what you
would really obtain
is real free energies only
from 0 to 0.1 or from between 1
and something like 0.8, 0.85.
And in the middle, you have
this famous miscibility
gap in which, really, the free
energy of the solid solution
is higher than the free
energy of the n compounds.
And so you have the max
error and the tangent.
And so what you have is the
composition of your system.
And so you can calculate
your phase diagram.
And at the end, for this system,
it would really look like this.
Below 820 kelvin, you
open a miscibility gap
in which, really,
the two systems
don't want to mix together.
And so in many ways,
semiconductor alloys
are really model solutions.
And below the
critical temperature,
they start to segregate.
And of course, you can do a
lot of other intriguing things.
That is, in your simulation,
you figure out, say,
what is the
distributions of, say,
gallium-phosphorus distance
or indium-phosphorus distances
at any given concentrations.
And what you
actually discover is
that there is a sort of
very bimodal distribution,
that there are short
distances with the phosphorus,
and there are long distance
with the phosphorus-- that
are, of course, due
to the fact that these
are gallium-phosphorus
distances and these are
indium-phosphorus distances.
But they sort of depends
with the concentration.
But those are things
that can be measured.
And so in this
sort of graph, I've
put an example of what
are the numbers that we
get from the Monte
Carlo simulations
on the Ising Hamiltonian and
what are actually the EXAES
results that people measure.
And you see, there is really
a very good agreement.
Say, these are the short
gallium phosphide distances
as a function of
concentration between what
the experiment measure and what
your thermodynamical DFT is
actually predicting.
And I think I'll skip this.
There were some other details
about epitaxial system.
But otherwise, I'm
worried I won't
be able to do the second part.
So this was the first example.
Again, what is important
there is that we
have a physical problem.
We have identified what are the
important degrees of freedom,
and we have calculated
those degrees of freedom
from calculations that
are actually manageable.
But those degrees of
freedom in those calculation
have given us the parameter of a
Hamiltonian that, in this case,
was a Ising-like long range
Hamiltonian in which we
can do sort of much more complex
statistical mechanics analysis.
And so we can actually
obtain phase diagrams.
That was one example.
The other example that
I want to show you
here is instead how
we sort of repeat
the same process
in order instead
to calculate Hamiltonians that
have a linear scaling cost.
That is, that allow
us to calculate
the electronic
structure and energies
of systems that
are really large,
that are sort of thousands or
tens of thousands of atoms.
And you know, this is because
this comes from some research
example.
We were interested
in sort of studying
what is the effect
on a carbon nanotube
of organic functionalization.
That is, what happens
if we take a ligand--
this would be--
it's a benzene ring.
So again, let's kind of
call it phenyl moiety.
And this sort of ring is
attached with a covalent bond
to an infinitely
longer carbon nanotube.
And people have
started doing this.
And of course, when
it happens, what you
have is a nanotube
that has a random array
of these funny rings.
So again, we have the
thermodynamical problem
of finding out what is the
effect of this configuration
of this order on some of
the intriguing properties
of the carbon nanotube.
Like, there are sort
of ballistic electrical
conductivity, that is
electrical conductivity, that
is independent of
length, so very different
from an ohmic conductor--
or what is their
thermal conductivity.
But again, we really don't have
the computational resources,
and no one has the
computational resources
to study, with density
functional theory, a system
with tens of thousands of atoms.
And you'll see this in sort
of the last part of the class,
really.
It's not just a matter of
waiting a few more years.
I mean, the scaling cost
kills us in many ways.
So we really need to
use sort of ingenuity.
And what we are going to
use here is this idea.
We want to break away from
this orthonormalization
constraint that is
really what drives
the cubic scaling of a system.
That is, what we want
to do is using a system
as sort of picture
in which we really
look at Kohn-Sham orbitals
that are localized,
so we don't have to worry about
orthonormality with orbitals
that are far away.
Because if two orbitals are
far away, and both of them
are localized, their
overlap is going to be 0.
And so they are
orthogonal by default,
without us having to
sort of impose that.
And the way we are
going to do this
is, again, a mapping from the
full density functional theory
calculation.
So we start--
I'm giving you here
the example of silicon.
If you look at the band
structure of silicon,
again, what you have
are very localized
core orbitals down there
that don't really have
any effect on the chemistry.
They corresponds to flat bands.
But what is interesting is
what the valence electrons do,
and this is sort of the
very celebrated band
structure of silicon.
This in particular is the
gamma point, so at 0, 0, 0.
And so because
silicon has two atoms
per unit cell, four
valence electrons per atom,
we have eight valence electrons.
Spin the generator.
So we have bands that
contain two electrons each.
Sorry.
So what we have is
four valence bands.
And you see, 1, 2, 3, 4.
As we move around
the Brillouin zone,
they can become the generator.
And those that are studying
semiconductor physics,
they will know that this is
the top of the valence band,
and we have heavy
holes and light holes
depending on the
curvature up here.
But so what is the electronic
structure of our problem?
Well, remember, the band
index and the quasimomentum k
across the Brillouin
zone are really
the quantum numbers for the
crystal, for my problem.
If I study a
molecule, and I have
a molecule with eight electrons,
I will have only four--
in the case of spin degeneracy--
eigenstates that are occupied.
If, instead of studying a
molecule with eight electrons,
I study a crystal with eight
electrons per unit cell,
instead of having four
states, I have four bands.
And the energy of
each eigenstate,
thanks to Bloch theorem,
can be cataloged
depending on this band index and
depending on the quasimomentum.
And the quasimomentum
really sort of tells me
how the phase of things changes
when we go from one unit cell
to the other.
The same concept takes
place also not in--
for the electronic eigenstates
but for the normal modes,
for the phonon
modes of a crystal.
We classify them
according to wavelength
and according to band index.
And so your infinite number
of electrons in the crystal
can all sort of be summarized
in this picture, in which we
have a continuum of states.
So if you want, we
have mapped the fact
that we had eight electrons
repeated infinitely
into a problem in which we have
eight electrons, that is four
bands, with a sort of
continuum variation,
depending on which
wavelength we are looking at.
And so this picture
sort of represents
all the possible occupied
states in your system
that are infinite but are
classified in a group of four
with a continuum index k.
Now, the interesting things
about quantum mechanics
is that you can change
your representation
and still look at
the same problem.
It's the same thing in
classical mechanics.
If you are sort of studying
something in three dimension,
you can rotate your
coordinate system.
And so your equation
of motion will change.
Your trajectory will change.
But really, you are just
moving everything accordingly,
and you are looking
at the same problem
in a different
coordinate system.
That is even more true in
quantum mechanics, in which you
can perform a unitary
transformation between all
your eigenstates and still
look at the same problem.
Usually, what we
sort of choose to be
is into a
representation in which
we are looking at eigenstates
of the Hamiltonian.
So each of these
states here is exactly
the characteristic of being an
eigenstate of the Hamiltonian.
You apply the Hamiltonian
to that state.
What you obtain
is a constant that
is the energy eigenvalue
times the state itself.
But we can mix this
around, and we can still
look at the same problem, just
in a different representation.
Exactly as in
classical mechanics,
we can do an orthogonal
transformation
of our coordinate system and
look at the same problem.
So what we can do is actually
do a unitary transformation,
a unitary rotation,
of our orbitals
and still look at
the same problem.
And again, without really going
into the details of what it is
and what quantum
mechanics is, it's
something that would
look like this.
That is, if we start from our
eigenstates, at each k point--
that is, at each point
in the Brillouin zone--
if we have those four bands,
we can mix them together
with a unitary transformation.
But not only that, we can
sort of mix those mixed bands
with all the other bands
at different k points
with the appropriate
unitary factor.
And so what we can obtain is
a new set of orbitals that
are, again, infinite and
that really represent
the same quantum
mechanical problem,
just sort of turned it around.
And our quantum
numbers that before,
where the band index
and the quasimomentum
become some new quantum
numbers, that will be-- again,
one of them will be
related to the bands.
So for silicon,
we'll go from 1 to 4.
And the other one will
count all the sort
of infinite number
of electrons that we
have when we go from one
isolated unit cell to one unit
cell periodically repeated.
And before, what we had
was a quasicontinuum,
basically, of wavelengths.
And in this new
representation, what we
have is a quasicontinuum
of localization vectors.
So we go from extended
Bloch orbitals
that are eigenstates
of the Hamiltonian
to localized orbitals in which
the electron is sitting in each
of the different unit cells.
And really, this is an
arbitrary transformation.
And these matrices are
sort of our parameters,
the sort of quantum mechanical
equivalent of the three Euler
angles that rotate the
Cartesian system from one
representation to another.
And so we can choose, say,
this set of transformation,
so that what we obtain is the
same quantum mechanical picture
but in a representation that
is as localized as possible.
And how we do that sort of
requires a lot of algebra.
But this is the sort of
very intriguing result
that takes place when we
actually make it in practice.
We take-- again, all these
states and each of them
is delocalized.
It's Bloch orbital
energy eigenstates
that is extended over
the whole crystal.
We mix all these things
together with a criterion
that those mixing
transformation are
chosen so that the new states
are as localized as possible.
And what we obtain at the
end is fairly beautiful.
If we look at, say, something
like silicon, again,
sort of a perennial
diamond structure,
one silicon atom
fourfold coordinated
with the other silicon atoms--
and it's a bit difficult to
see, but what we would have
is that one silicon
atom, in red,
is connected to
four silicon atoms.
And this blue over
blue silicon atom
is connected to other
four silicon atoms.
And the localized
orbital that you obtain
is really what the chemist would
have told us probably in 1930.
It's really a covalent bond
between the two orbitals.
So what we have is that
these two atoms here
are connected by an
orbital that has,
really, this pile up of covalent
charge between those two atoms.
And there is a certain amount
of sort of back-bonding
between each of those two
atoms and the remaining three
neighbors.
So this is how the localized
orbital looks like.
And that's been just obtained
by a unitary transformation.
But when we have
this player here,
it becomes very easy
now to construct
the electronic structure
of a system that
might have some amount of
configurational disorder.
Because, if instead
of having somewhere,
say, silicon-silicon in an
infinite silicon matrix,
we have maybe gallium and
arsenic for a moment locally.
Well, maybe what we can do, and
I'll show you how we'll do it,
maybe we can put there the
exact orbital corresponding
to the gallium arsenic bond.
And if you look at it, it's
actually going to be-- again,
because things are
similar, it's going
to be very similar to
the silicon orbital.
The gallium arsenic
covalent bonds
is just, because
of the difference
of electronic activity,
sort of tilted more
towards the electronegative
arsenic in this problem.
Or say, again, to
give you the feeling,
it's nothing less than the sort
of standard chemical picture.
If we have a system
that is still silicon,
but it's amorphous silicon--
and I've got here atoms around.
But amorphous
silicon is something
in which a tetrahedral
short range holder is still
preserved on average but
long range holder is lost.
Well, atoms that are
tetrahedrally coordinated
won't have a perfect
109 degrees angles,
but their bonds still
look very much like those.
And sometimes, you have atoms
that are five-fold coordinated.
And so they have their own bond.
And if you want,
these are really
what we call the LEGO bricks
of electronic structure.
That is, in a very
complex system,
the electronic
structure of the system
is going to be made up locally
by the appropriate orbitals
that corresponds to
the local environment.
And the nature and physics
is inherently local,
so there is a large
degree of transferability.
And again, to give you a sort
of more feeling for this,
suppose that instead of
looking at a crystal,
we look at a molecule.
We look at something
like a benzene ring.
And you go to a representation
in which states, instead
of being eigenstates
of the Hamiltonian,
are localized states.
What you see are electronic
states that are really
carbon-hydrogen
single bonds, or what
you see are carbon-carbon
single bonds, or what you see
are carbon-carbon
double bonds, in which
you have both this orbital
and this reflection
across the symmetry plane
of the benzene molecule.
So really, what you are seeing
is very intuitive chemical
picture.
But the way it's been
obtained is actually
from an exact transformation of
our quantum mechanical problem,
solving density functional
theory, that is,
with a certain
degree of accuracy.
And we'll see now
how we apply this
to the case of carbon nanotubes,
because what we really
want to do is study chemical
disorder on these carbon
nanotubes.
And carbon nanotube is nothing
else than a sheet of graphite--
that is what is called
the graphene sheet--
that has been rolled over
together to create a tube.
So if you take this
hexagonal lattice,
there are sort of discrete
infinite way of rolling things
together.
And the way the carbon
nanotube community
has agreed to sort
of use a nomenclature
is by defining what is
called a chiral vector, that,
in this case here,
would be this CH vector.
So if, on a graphene
sheet, you define a vector,
that is really just
an integer number
of times the two a1 and a2
primitive lattice vectors--
that is, once you have
defined this green CH,
you have defined your
nanotube, by saying
that you are cutting
the graphene sheet
perpendicular to this vector
and rolling what you have cut,
so that the top of the
vector touches the bottom.
And so you have sort
of a perfect cylinder.
And then there is
a nomenclature.
And you can sort of--
a generic nanotube
will be called armchair,
zig-zag, or chiral nanotube,
depending on how you have
rolled things around.
And so if your chiral
vector is an n number of a1s
and an n number of a2,
equal, your chiral vector
will be this blue vector here.
And so what you
are going to do is,
you are going to
roll the nanotube so
that perpendicular to the
direction of the tube,
you can clearly see this
sort of zig-zag pattern.
And so an armchair--
sorry, a zig-zag-- oh, sorry.
A zig-zag nanotube
is the one in which
you have a chiral
vector that is made
by an integer number
of times a1 and zero
number a2 or vice versa.
So in the form n, 0 or 0, m.
And so you see, this blue
vector for the zig-zag
is going to be 1,
2, 3, 4, 5 times a1.
So this will be the
zig-zag nanotube,
and you see this
zig-zag pattern.
If, instead, you choose n for
a1 equal to the n for a2, what
you have is a vector that
goes in this direction,
like the red vector here.
And so what you are
doing is actually
sort of cutting the
nanotube like this
and rolling it together.
And again, now perpendicular
to the axis of the nanotube,
you see this pattern.
That is called an
armchair pattern.
And so an armchair nanotube is
identified by these two quantum
numbers.
And then identical
zig-zag is n, 0 or 0, n.
And everything else has a
sort of more ordered chirality
and is called, generically
speaking, a chiral nanotube.
OK, so this is how
they look like.
You see, a zig-zag, very
long in this direction.
We cut it, we see
the zig-zag pattern.
An armchair, we cut, and we see
that sort of hexagonal pattern
that, for some reason,
is called an armchair.
And now the
interesting bit comes
when we look at the band
structure of this system.
We could have started, say, from
the band structure of graphite
or graphene, in which,
again, the Brillouin zone--
the extended Brillouin
zone is this hexagon.
And what happens is a bit
difficult to visualize.
But actually, what
happens is that there
are only six points--
so the black dots there--
at which they are
unoccupied states
touch the occupied states.
So usually-- and we have
seen it over and over again--
in something like
a metal, we will
have maybe a band like this.
And then we'll have Fermi energy
that cuts the occupied states
from the unoccupied states.
In graphite, the band
dispersion is much more exotic.
It actually looks like this.
In certain points of
the Brillouin zone,
it's actually sort
of straight lines.
You'll see it in a moment.
And the Fermi surface
is exactly here.
So there is only-- the
Fermi energy is here.
The Fermi surface is on a point.
And seen from
above, if you want,
these are where these combs
are that I've sort of cut there
in a profile.
What happens when you go
from graphene to a nanotube?
Well, instead of
having a system that
is infinitely B-dimensional,
you get a system in which,
by rolling one of
the dimensions, what
you do actually is you
quantize your quantum
numbers in one direction.
So you still have
a Brillouin zone
that is a continuum in the
direction of the tube axis.
But because you have rolled it,
maybe you have only 10 hexagons
instead of an infinite number
of hexagons in the direction
perpendicular to the axis.
Now, what you are
effectively doing
is really looking at the
band structure only along
a certain number of cuts
of this Brillouin zone.
And so depending on how you roll
your system, what you can have
is that this subset of
lines that corresponds
to having a continuum
index in one direction
become a discrete index,
because in one direction,
we go from infinite hexagon to
a finite number of hexagons.
And so depending on
how many and what
is the orientation
of the cut, we
can have that these lines cross
or do not cross these points.
And if they cross those points,
we'll have a metallic nanotube.
If they don't, we'll have
a semiconducting nanotube.
So just a very slight
change in orientation
in the chirality vector might
allow us to miss this point
and make something that was
metallic into a semiconductor.
And the rule to remember
this is trivial.
If the difference
between the indices
is 0 or a multiple of
three, your nanotube
is going to be metallic.
Otherwise, it's semiconducting.
So say, all armchair
nanotubes are metallic,
because m is equal to n,
so the difference is 0.
So they are metallic.
Zig-zag nanotubes,
well, only 1 out of 3
is going to be metallic.
6, 0 is going to be metallic.
7, 0, 8, 0 are semiconducting.
9, 0 is metallic, and
so on and so forth.
And this sort of
only breaks down
when we have very
narrow nanotubes
in which this sort of model
picture of what is called band
folding starts to break apart,
because the way we have thought
of the nanotube is as being
identical to a perfect sheet
of graphene that has been
quantized in one direction.
But really, there is curvature.
And if the nanotube is narrow,
there is a lot of curvature.
And so that sort of might change
things around a little bit.
But so here is an example.
You see, if you have
a metallic nanotube,
like in this case, when you
quantize it in one direction,
you are rolling it,
you actually end up
with lines that go
through the black points.
And so what you have is that
your band structure there
sort of sees these cones
of the graphite system.
If you have, say, in this case
a semiconducting a0 system, when
you quantize anything in
that perpendicular direction,
your lines actually do not
go through the black points.
And so you never
encounter a corner,
and you never find that gap.
And again, a very slight
change in orientation
can give you a very variable
gap and can bring you
to be metallic very quickly.
And so we start really going
again into the details.
We really need to take
all our occupied states--
that is, the one below
here that I'm not showing,
everything below
the Fermi energy
that is here for this
metallic nanotube--
and we actually want to take
a little bit of the states
above, because those
are also important.
And with all these states, the
red, the blue, and the black--
so all of the occupied states
and a bit of the unoccupied
one--
we want to sort of
mix them together
and find what are the localized
orbitals coming from this.
And I won't go into the details
on how we sort of extracted
those when you have some of the
discontinuity that comes about
in a metal.
But so basically,
what's happening
is that we start from
our electronic structure
calculation, maybe of
the carbon nanotube
with a functionalized ligand.
And in a new quantum
mechanical representation,
what we have obtained are
sort of the building blocks
of the pristine nanotube,
and the building
blocks of the ligand, and
things like what is exactly
the orbital that
connects a carbon
atom in the ligand to a
carbon atom in the sidewall,
with sort of full first
principle precision.
And so with these blocks
now, we can actually
construct not only
the band structure
and the electronic structure
of this system periodically
repeated, but also a system in
which the ligand is first here,
here, and then here, with
all the chemical disorder
that we want.
And because the orbitals do
not overlap with each other,
the computational cost of doing
this is very, very reduced.
Because basically, in
our new representation,
orbitals that are far away are
orthogonal with each other,
when we actually represent
the Hamiltonian--
remember, in a lot of
your PWSCF calculation,
you have represented
the Hamiltonian
in a plane wave basis set.
And so in a plane
wave basis set,
your Hamiltonian has the
diagonally dominant part,
that is g squared over 2.
But then it also terms
all over the place
that corresponds to the Fourier
transform of the potential.
When we actually
represent the Hamiltonian
on this basis of localized
orbitals, what you have
is that this is truly
diagonally dominant.
And as soon as we
consider orbitals
that are far away
from each other,
there is no Hamiltonian
matrix between them.
If we calculate the matrix
element between this,
the Hamiltonian,
and this green one,
it's going to be 0, because
they really do not overlap.
So this is what is called a
sparse diagonally dominant
Hamiltonian.
And diagonalizing
this is something
that actually doesn't
require cubic scaling
but only requires
linear scaling.
So one can really sort of
study very large systems.
And to show you an
enlargement of a cutout
from a perfect nanotube, you
see, this is what you get.
You get orbitals that look
either as beautiful sort
of bonding combination
of sp2 orbitals--
if you think, we
know from chemistry
that the carbon
is sp2 hybridized.
So it means that the
graphitic backbone
is given by a
bonding combination
of an sp2 orbital sitting
here and an sp2 sitting here.
And the same happens here.
And then there is a set of pz
orbitals sitting on each tube.
And when those
mix together, they
give rise to the metallic
graphitic-like bonds.
And again, this looks a
lot like a pz orbital,
but it is nowhere similar to
the pz orbital of a carbon atom.
It's the pz orbital specific
to a carbon nanotube.
So with this, we
can-- as previously
in the case of the alloys, we
can first validate our system.
That is, we can
start constructing
the electronic
structure of something
that we can also fully
calculate from first principle.
And we can compare them
and these continuous lines
from the models and dots
from the full calculation.
And you see, the
model works perfectly
and doesn't describe
the higher energy
bonds that have
not been included
in our sort of orbital
construction procedure.
But for all the bonds that
we wanted to consider,
this is perfect.
And once we sort of feel
confident that this works,
we can actually use
it to calculate the--
let me actually go farther--
we can actually
use it to calculate
the electronic
structure of systems
that are too large to attack
directly, something like this.
This has just a conducting
region of 3,000 atoms
and a very long sort
of semi-infinite leads
on the side.
And we can figure out
a lot of what happens,
say, to the ballistic
conductivity of this system.
And I'm not really
going into the details.
I wanted to go before
concluding to a previous slide
here, in which I was
actually showing how,
in practice, the matrix
element between a localized
orbital and another
localized orbital
changes as a function
of the distance,
say, as we sit on a
carbon atom, and we
look at the overlap
between the pz orbital here
and we move away
from the nanotube.
And you see, in a
semi-logarithmic scale,
we have very good
exponential decay.
Certain point goes into
the numerical noise.
And we can really look at--
validate what are the effects
of our truncation by cutting
shorter and shorter
Hamiltonians, by neglecting
a large number of terms
that are far away.
And you see, there is
almost an invisible effect
on the band structure.
So that really sort of tells us
how much localized things are,
how much they overlap,
and if you want,
tells us how long range or
short range chemistry is.
That is very important
when we consider
one of this configuration.
So with this, I'll conclude.
Again, the two
important messages
that you want to
remember from this class
is how you take a
physical problem,
and you can use density
functional calculation
to find out what are
the important parameters
and construct a model
for your energy.
The first case where
configurational variables
inducing relaxation and gives
us Ising-like Hamiltonian,
in this case, we have
localized orbitals.
And once we determine those,
from a small calculation
or from a fragment,
we can actually
calculate the very large system.